bonjour guillaume duval merci de
répondre à nos questions la france
va-t-elle suspendre cette taxation du
numérique pour éviter des sanctions
américaines
je ne crois pas que ce soit dans les
tuyaux pour l'instant donc ce qu'est ce
qui est prévu c'est de laisser donc la
taxation est entrée en vigueur ce qui
est prévu c'est de laisser jusqu'à la
fin de l'année
le temps de négocier dans le cadre de l'
ocde donc il y à des négociations
internationales qui semble bien engagée
jusque là qui sont prévues dans ce cadre
là pour harmoniser la taxation notamment
des multinationales du secteur du
numérique d'ici la fin de cette année
donc ce qui est prévu c'est de laisser
ces négociations se terminer et donc
donald trump les américains ne prendrai
pas des sanctions telles que c'était
annoncé jusque-là contre contre la
france en cas de mise en place de cette
de cette taxe on en est là c'est quelque
chose d'assez important malgré tout
parce que on pouvait redouter en
particulier que les états unis
souhaitent se retirer de cette
négociation internationale que j'ai une
des formes de d'action contre le
multilatéralisme des américains soit
effectivement de renoncer à tous les
efforts qui ont été engagées depuis la
crise en matière d'harmonisation fiscale
internationale notamment sur la
fiscalité des multinationales donc le
fait qu'il reste engagé que donald trump
reste engagé dans cette démarche est
quelque chose de très important en soi
on peut évidemment regretté que l'europe
ait fait preuve une fois de plus à la
fois de plus l usy l'intimité et de
division donc c'est notamment le cas des
allemands donc le gouvernement allemand
a refusé de suivre le gouvernement
français sur la voie de cette taxe sur
le numérique
parce que les allemands redoutent est
justement des réactions américaines sur
les voitures en particulier
donc c'est pour eux un
jeu extrêmement important sur le plan du
commerce extérieur mais aussi des
emplois en allemagne
donc c'est la raison pour laquelle la
france s'est retrouvée isolée sur cette
action mais dans l'immédiat donc le
danger de sanction particulière contre
la france semble écartée
donc le commissaire européen en charge
de ce domaine avait annoncé que l'europe
serait solidaire avec la france mais on
sait que ça va pas forcément très loin
fall l'europe n'est pas forcément
capable d'aller très loin de manière
unique pour réagir des sanctions
américaines
donald trump a trouvé un terrain
d'entente on sait le 15 janvier avec
pékin donc
idem avec paris est-ce que donald trump
calme le jeu en ce début d'année ou bien
est-ce que c'est sa technique de
pression maximum sur ses rivaux et qui
portent finalement ses fruits donc pour
l'instant ce qu'on peut dire c'est
surtout que l'enjeu essentiel pour
donald trump
c'est la chine et ça reste la chine donc
il a trouvé un premier accord avec les
chinois pour calmer le jeu dans
l'immédiat mais on rentre en fait dans
le dur sur les questions les plus
importantes pour les américains qui sont
qui concerne la propriété intellectuelle
le
les moyens pour eux de préserver leur
avance technologique dans le domaine de
la high tech
donc c'est là dessus que les américains
vont négocier toute l'année avec les
chinois et ça c'est difficile ça va
rester difficile
donc on peut penser que donald trump n'a
pas sûr pensé utile pour lui pour sa
politique de d'ouvrir déjà un deuxième
front avec l'europe autour du numérique
d'autant que ces acteurs du numérique ne
sont pas non plus il faut pas l'oublier
forcément les plus grands alliés de
donald trump dans la politique
américaine donc ce sont des acteurs qui
qu'il a lui aussi plutôt dans le viseur
pour d'autres raisons en matière de
politique intérieure américaine et de
domination sur les marchés américains
eux mêmes et entre paris et washington
justement dans cet accord selon vous
quelles sont les conditions qui
pourraient avantager ou désavantagé
l'une ou l'autre des parties
ce que j'ai moi j'ai pas entendu dans
cet accord entre paris et washington
quelles seraient les conditions qui
pourraient avantager ou désavantagé
l'une ou l'autre des parties
donc la france est dans une situation un
peu particulière paquet pas du tout la
même situation que que l'allemagne par
exemple vis-à-vis des etats-unis un
temps que dans la mesure où les
exportations françaises vers les etats
unis sont très inférieures à ce qu'elles
sont pour l'industrie allemande
donc c'est vrai que ça concerne certains
secteurs d'activité précis qui pourrait
être assez fortement impactée dans les
vins et les produits de luxe etc
mais quand même l'enjeu pour la france
enfin la sensibilité de la france à des
sanctions américaines et plus faibles en
revanche le marché français et non
négligeable à la fois pour les acteurs
du numérique pour les acteurs du cinéma
etc
pour beaucoup d'acteurs américains et ce
serait je pense un risque
ils le perçoivent sans doute comme un
risque de se fâcher avec la france avec
emmanuel macron qui semble plutôt malgré
tout en position de force au sein de
l'europe aujourd'hui donc c'est je crois
la une des raisons pour lesquelles il
cherche plutôt à calmer le jeu dans
l'immédiat il y à aussi l'ensemble des
problèmes extérieurs des problèmes
géopolitiques sur lequel la france est
un des seuls acteurs européens qui peut
peser réellement compte tenu de sa
puissance militaire de la disposition de
de l'arme nucléaire etc
donc je crois que du point de vue
américain ce n'est pas la priorité
aujourd'hui de se fâcher encore plus
avec l'europe et avec la france ces mots
de la fin merci guillaume duval d'avoir
répondu à nos questions je rappelle que
vous êtes éditorialiste à alternatives
économiques